right going live a minute early it's a
particularly busy time of the year so
we'll
wait and see whether some other people
show up in the meantime you can see my
bookshelf that i know so many people are
fascinated by behind me you could
probably also hear sirens
in the distance we live not too far from
a fire station and from milwaukee police
district one
so
those are a
not constant but often uh
happening thing so i've been done one of
these political theory and practice
discussions for a while in part because
i've been so busy with coursework and
stoicon and
all these other stuff
going on
but this one is one i've been looking
forward to for
a while
and it's something that i think can be
very useful for a non-american audience
in understanding
why american politics and culture is the
way it is but i think it can also be
incredibly useful for
a lot of people within the american
context who don't
understand why
change can't be produced or
accountability can't be
demanded as easily and a lot of it has
to do with what we can call in a very
broad sense
localism that's not really the right
word for it in part because localism
typically means like focusing on local
politics local issues affecting change
at a local level
in this case we're talking about
something that's a
structural aspect of american culture
politics economics all these things
connected up and i chose as my theme
there is no system
because when it comes to many of the
things that we talk about
in politics
and we want to you know express uh
dissatisfaction about or the need for
change or any of these these sorts of
things
we often
talk in terms of the system
and i think in a lot of countries there
really is a the system for that sort of
thing so
the the three things that i wanted to
focus on as examples of this are
education
health care and
policing and criminal justice which
would include prisons as
well there is no system in america for
any of those
there are systems in other places so
when we talk about a national health
care system for example in great britain
there really is a national health care
system and it may be fragmented in
certain ways and there may be problems
with it and sometimes people fall
through the cracks and stuff like that
but there is a system there is a set of
governmental agencies there are rules
that apply across the board there is the
possibility of taking bad actors
and you know
giving them sanctions removing them from
the system there are possibilities of
changing the system through legislation
or through uh the way the executive
works or you know just the way the
governmental agencies uh structure
themselves we can say similar things
about their being in in many countries
a
education system and it may have
outliers like there may be
religious schools that don't fit into
the governmental system in some cases
religious schools even do fit into the
governmental system and there is an
educational
system so for example um you know some
of my videos have been used as part of
the portuguese national curriculum uh
which includes some philosophy in the
10th and 11th grade there's a system
there right um we can also talk about
this in terms of policing you know there
and again we'll use great britain as an
example
you can be
you know a police officer
assigned to
a you know a department or district or
whatever they call them up in the north
of england or you can be you know down
in the very southern part you can be in
a city you can be in the countryside but
you belong to a national
system
and if you screw up
your screw-ups follow you from place to
place to place right
so this is this is something that's very
different here in america
when it comes to many many things we do
not have a system we do have systems
when it comes to some things right we
have a
national interstate you know
transportation system right we have the
amtrak train system which is national
not a very good one unfortunately
because it's typically underfunded not
because it's you know
the amtrak people don't want to do a
good job we have a national postal
system although that's supplemented
considerably by all these other ways of
delivering packages
but
when it comes to education we do not
have a system we have a department of
education but the department of
education only dictates things at the
very very high levels
what really happens in education depends
totally on what's happening on a local
and on a state level
similarly we do not have a national
policing
or prison
or criminal justice system we have all
sorts of other things instead that i'll
talk about in a moment and we don't have
a national health care system as a
matter of fact that's one of the things
where
we are really at a major disadvantage as
the covid uh
pandemic has shown us you know um we
have a lot of people who
don't have access to health care um even
after you know
things like obamacare and we'll talk
about that in a moment as well
so let's talk about education first but
actually before that instead of saying
you might say well so there's no system
what the hell is there
there are systems plural
and they interconnect and interlock with
each other and sometimes conflict with
each other and sometimes don't look the
same as each other and sometimes are
engaged in polemics with each other
and sometimes support each other
sometimes
do the opposite of support hinder each
other
and there's you know all sorts of
permeability to
money coming in or corporations or other
interests taking a role in it and a lot
of it gets dictated by
administrators or by legislators on a
local level who may in fact be just as
bad as our national legislators um you
know we we don't have like the best
people in office much of the time in
either party i mean one party is
particularly bad the other party is is
you know half and half uh when it comes
to competency um
and so we have a whole bunch of
interconnected systems many of which are
not what they pretend to be
and so when somebody generalizes about
the system you know we need to change
the system
they're usually laboring under a
collective delusion
you know it's not possible to change the
national policing system because we
don't have one it's not possible to
change the national education system
because we don't have one right we could
go on and on with examples like this so
let's talk about education and then
we're going to break it down into what
we call k through 12 which also includes
pre-k you know pre-kindergarten k-12
means through 12th grade being a senior
in high school so it includes elementary
school middle school high school and
anything else you might want to call it
along the way like junior high or you
know uh pre pre elementary and any of
those sorts of things so kids from
basically
three years old up to 18 sometimes 19
when they're graduating we've got that
and then we've got our college and
university systems what we here in
america call um
uh
post-secondary you know education right
and some people get confused because we
have undergraduate and graduate and that
doesn't map exactly onto college and
university and other places so just just
put the dividing line at like
up to high school and then anything
after that
so let's talk about k-12 who decides how
things work there is a department of
education right and the department of
education can have certain guidelines
you know like the common core became
part of it its implementation depends on
the local school
system and there usually are systems
right so a school typically unless it's
an independent private school is not
going to be totally on its own it'll be
part of a school district or in indiana
a school corporation right my kids went
to school corporations
you might say what's the difference well
you know a corporation is a corporation
it's uh
you know
ostensibly not-for-profit but profit
motives get involved in there very
easily and
there's a lot of interaction between
business and education
so each local area has got its own
school districts and then that has to be
funded much of the funding comes from
local property taxes and so if you live
in a low tax area you probably don't
have a lot of money to educate your
students compared to people who live in
rich
areas which have higher property taxes
and which can afford a lot of things so
here in the milwaukee the other for
example the milwaukee public schools are
drastically underfunded as a matter of
fact if you want to help out
students today
you could write a check or make a
donation to the friends of the milwaukee
public school there was just a charity
that helps out the milwaukee public
schools
and that's because of the way our
politics work
you know the state sometimes puts in
some money
to help out
some states do some states don't it's
totally dependent on which of the 50
states you live in and which of the
municipalities you live in
standards change from state to state i
know you know some of you know that like
in republican dominated areas there's
this big push to like you know be
against critical race theory and you
know make sure that that won't be a part
of our our schools which is you know
largely [ __ ]
and you know crazy delusion on the part
of the people who are involved in it but
um be that as it may
they're trying to produce changes within
the districts they're also finding out
how difficult it is to really change
things uh for what they view as the
better which would be the worst for most
people um and and so there's there's
this inertia that's that's produced it's
very difficult to get things
changed or done
in many respects unless you control
the school board right or you control
the particular school now in addition to
all these school systems right uh across
a particular state and then each state
has got its own patchwork of these
things we have all these independent
schools as well
some of which are are religious
right um the three largest uh parochial
school systems are catholic lutheran and
seventh-day adventist interestingly
enough
um but there's also schools that are run
by
um
you know corporations or or
organizations that originate in say
china right we've got one of those here
in milwaukee
we have all sorts of other schools that
are affiliated with other groups and
interests and stuff like that
it can often be difficult to find out
accurate information about these and you
often have to do a lot of digging and
they have to teach some of the same
standards that each state will apply but
each state is totally different than the
other i mean if you go to school in a
place like mississippi the standards are
low as a matter of fact across the south
you know with the exception of like
maybe virginia
standards are pretty low by comparison
to midwestern states and you know new
england states or new york or you know
the west coast or stuff like that plain
states are struggling immensely
with population loss much of which is
younger people and some school districts
may require their students to be bussed
two hours to get to school in two hours
to get back
very very different student experiences
very different parent experiences very
different uh
accessibility to
having your voice heard
what goes you know one mile down the
road may not be the case another mile
down the road people don't often realize
this until they start
getting involved
what about our college and university
system is there a system there's no
system
there are some basic standards like you
you need to be accredited well unless
you're not accredited or you're a
for-profit college or things like that
some of them have been reined in
some of them have been quite predatory
including on military people um
you know trump university was just one
of many examples of fake schools
essentially
um
within any given state and we have again
50 states in the united states you are
going to find a state university system
which will
be you know ostensibly one big system
but each university is going to be kind
of its own animal
and
things are going to be different from
one college or university in that system
to another you know if we take wisconsin
the two largest ones are madison
which is the flagship university set in
the capital uw milwaukee which is you
know also very important that's where my
daughter my oldest daughter is going um
studying musical theater really great
program there
um oshkosh which is the third largest
and then it's like all these other
satellites like you know eau claire and
lacrosse and green bay
and stout and
um
i'm blanking on the white water white
water's the one you go to for business
you know and each has its own particular
thing and each is its own entity
similarly uh in illinois you know i went
to southern illinois university
carbondale there's and it's said
carbondale because there's two southern
illinois universities there's southern
illinois university carbondale southern
university uh southern illinois
university edwardsville right and then
there's western university western
illinois and eastern illinois and you
know illinois university in champaign
urbana university of illinois at chicago
right
all these different
entities that are all part of
one system but are being managed quite
differently from each other then you
have
all the other schools
you know most of our elite schools the
the big ones that have gigantic
endowments
and massive cultural force
they are not public schools
harvard university
university of chicago
you know
second tier ones like university of
notre dame that desperately wants to be
an ivy league and you know is basically
sold out it's a lot of its ethos to try
to get that
marquette university just down the road
these are all private institutions they
may be affiliated with a church
but that affiliation is probably very
very loose at this point in time so
marquette university
is ostensibly a jesuit university but
they haven't been a jesuit university
for 20 years you know they don't live up
to any of those those values and stuff
like that
and um
each one is its own entity and you could
say well there's got to be something
that like holds them together like
accreditation
yeah there's there's there's some
regional accrediting bodies and then
there's professional accreditation that
you can get
um but accreditation in many respects is
kind of a joke i i actually you know got
to see a uni uh not a university a
college lie
to the accreditors about some things
because i was a consultant actually
getting to see the documents and i knew
that the stuff that they were saying was
like complete lies we have a culture of
assessment they didn't have a culture of
assessment and the accreditors didn't
check
so
what do you do in a case like that you
know and when we talk about things like
um you know
cancel culture on campus or
we talk about free speech or we talk
about uh you know academic
um
freedom or we talk about admission
scandals
you've got to understand
this is not something where you can take
an instance of one college and then
generalize about the whole system
because there is no system right what
happens at evergreen happens at
evergreen and that happens at evergreen
and that's not happening at the next
college down the road unless you can
actually
show
that there's some internal connection if
some speaker is you know shouted down at
university of chicago that doesn't mean
a damn thing about you know what what
goes on at marquette university or even
universities within chicago like
university of illinois at chicago or
dominic or not dominican um benedictine
or
depaul or any of these sorts of things
so just looking at cases you know that
happen at one particular place doesn't
tell us a lot about what's going on at
others
and um
i mean we can make some really broad
generalizations but that's about it and
if you want to change the policies of
places it is incredibly difficult to do
um let's talk about so that's education
let's talk about policing
policing is even more of a mess i mean
do we have federal police yes we have
all these like you know the atf and we
have the fbi and we have the federal
marshals
they only get involved in certain kinds
of cases and very often they're like 49
steps behind whatever the locals are
doing
and local police departments can be
incredibly powerful think about the
corruption and abuses that have been
going on
in chicago police department
since the beginning all the way up to
today where we still see
terrible things being done by chicago
cops you know not to say that all the
chicago cops are bad there's some good
apples but they're always at you know
risk of being corrupted by the vast
amount of rotten apples in those barrels
you know right now we're seeing police
unions which really i think don't even
have a right to exist because of the
terrible stuff that they've done over
the years concealing corruption and
abuses
they really ought to be disbanded
tomorrow police unions um
standing in the way of covet
inoculations that you know where does
protect and serve come in you know
protect us from the the cops
and their
their uh entitlement and their uh
attitude of we're not gonna follow you
know the rules that everybody else in
society has to you know
we have
literally thousands tens of thousands of
police departments across the united
states
every one of which is its own entity a
cop can be fired for egregious conduct
and it does happen sometimes
in one municipality and go get a job as
a cop right down the road in another one
prime example of this is the guy in
wauwatosa who's killed several people on
the job
and he was fired by wauwatosa he got
hired by waukesha county sheriffs
so you know
it's very difficult to hold police
accountable the only exception is of
course when they're like blowing the
whistle on other police and then they're
held accountable very quickly by their
own fellow
cops
this is this is very much hindered by
the fact that every single town can have
its own police department every county
can have its own sheriff
the state police are the state police
right and just here in in milwaukee
prime example of this just a block from
here
jurisdictions change i mentioned that
we're very at the very beginning that
we're part of milwaukee police district
one
if i'm in the park and i see something
going on i have to call
not the milwaukee police but the
milwaukee county sheriff's because they
handle the park
right so i mean not that the milwaukee
police won't necessarily respond but
they'll probably kick it over to the
sheriffs
and
we have lots and lots of stuff like this
i i used to live on a county line
and i you know there'd be something
happening across the county line if i
called our sheriffs they wouldn't do
anything about it i'd have to call the
other county sheriffs right
and you know if one is corrupt and the
other one isn't
that's not connected to each other you
know um not to say we can't like try to
push
politically for police to be held
accountable but it's incredibly
difficult because of this this factor
same thing goes for prisons and jails
every single county has its own jails
right
and then each state has its own
department of corrections or bureau of
corrections or whatever they happen to
call it and each one is a separate
entity from all of the others prisons
are terribly uh you know run and
regulated in large part many many abuses
go on in american prisons that wouldn't
be tolerated in some other places and
it's in part because of the fact that
it's you know there's no system there
are only systems and each one requires
its own examination and oversight and
accountability
and they're not accountable all to the
same
place right
um
health care
another big mess for americans right
there is no national health care system
you might say well what about the
affordable care act obamacare what that
actually created was state marketplaces
where each state would have its own
private insurance companies that you
then could purchase
on the marketplace and you know you
might get a
subsidy for it or you might not
depending on how much money you're
making we were on the affordable care
act marketplace here in wisconsin
hours and hours and hours of online
paperwork and sometimes things falling
through things not being done right
and
um
[Music]
you know it was my my wife is the one
who handles these things she is
brilliant she's actually worked in you
know financial uh things before and she
understands how systems work and i would
hear her on the phone for hours at a
time trying to get you know our our
coverage and then trying to get it you
know things paid for and i would think
to myself how would an ordinary person
who doesn't have the kind of experience
and
persistence that she does how would they
actually get their insurance and get it
to work for them
most americans are still getting their
insurance through their employers if
they are getting insurance
it's often quite crappy
things are not covered we don't have a
national healthcare system instead we
have all of these interlocking
other systems and they don't work well
together and many americans are getting
really crappy healthcare as a result the
only the only exception to this is like
you know look at when we made vaccines
uh essentially free for people because
we want them inoculated against a
pandemic that's killing people it showed
what we could do
but we don't do it instead
we have you know all of these different
hospitals some of whom are actually
owned by venture capitalists you know
they've become part of a hospital group
and different hospitals have different
standards that they're requiring of
their doctors nurses orderlies all the
different people
um
it is just a
mess and it varies considerably not just
from state to state but from county to
county
if you live here in wisconsin
and you live down here in the milwaukee
area you can get access to quality
health care
if you live out in the countryside
particularly the farther north you go
it's a crap shoot
you may or may not have access to decent
health care
it's very dependent
on where you live and in part who you
know and what you know
so these are three examples of things
where there is no system
and to try to reform it to try to
produce a national system as we've seen
you know with with democrats trying to
introduce something like a single-payer
healthcare thing everybody oh i won't
get to keep my doctor and all sorts of
[ __ ] that gets you know put out
there you see how difficult it is to
change these things
we might be stuck with this forever and
you know some people might say well
there is a good side to this local
control local autonomy
yes and no
it's
some people's local control the the
elites the ones who have access the ones
who know how the system works and are
working the system
more often than anybody else there there
are people you know who are doing very
well with the american you know policing
systems and criminal justice systems or
the education systems or the health care
system but they're not the majority of
americans and if you want to understand
why americans are often so
frustrated why there's this this you
know
seething resentment it's not just
economic issues of like oh jobs have
been outsourced overseas it's because of
in super important areas of life health
care education policing
so many americans are just screwed
and there's little that they can do
about it it's not just that they can't
find jobs it's that when they come home
from their job or when they take time
off from their job to go pick up their
kid from school they find out that that
crazy crap has been happening at school
or their kids aren't learning anything
you know or their schools are dumps you
know and the the school right down the
road is great
or they get hassled by the cops and
there's nothing they can do about it
because the cops are acting with
impunity because there's no
overall system just the system that's in
place for that particular municipality
or
they you know take time off to go to the
doctor and can't get the health care
that they need and when they do get
anything it costs an arm and a leg
by the way affordable care act the
insurance that we had
you had a huge deductible
and then on top of that even when you'd
met your deductible you still paid extra
i mean
this is this is the american
you know if we want to use the word
system this is the american system and
it's a system of crap
how did we get here you know there's a
long long story to be told about that
i'm more interested in a diagnosis of
where we stand in the present
and
there's um
there's a lot of other areas that we
could talk about as well
where there is no system
um that in you know where it interlocks
with these think about libraries and how
every single place has its own library
system but there's always this talk
about well maybe we don't have to have
libraries there's places that want to
close them down
and every university has its own library
and all these other things we could talk
about lots and lots of other systems
all right so let's talk about some of
the things that are coming up hawkins
says what do you think about defund the
police i think that one's pretty much
dead in the water as a slogan we hash
that out
you know as a society over the last two
years
it's it's misleading i mean if what you
mean by defund the police is hold them
accountable
and um you know reduce their
their monetary uh inputs um you're not
defunding them you're actually
regulating them and you're actually
selectively funding them and stuff like
that to talk about totally defunding the
police that's pretty much a non-starter
these days and it's a non-starter in
most most municipalities get your feet
on the ground
and and see what you know people think
in the places that are being most
impacted once you get past the like you
know f the police kind of sentiment and
you say yes well should we get rid of
the police altogether people are like
yeah that's that's not really a starter
so we need much more realistic proposals
and we need much more local
accountability and that's not going to
come through
massive you know slogans or anything
like that it's going to come through the
persistence of
going in over and over and over again
and looking at things in the local level
and saying we got to do something about
this this here you know
any other
questions
comments people want to
make about
i mean this is very this is different in
america than it is in many other places
and i think this is something
that is
um
you know if you come from a place that
has a national health care system you'd
be like well why don't the americans
just like get get their act together and
have a national health care system you
know or you know if you think if you
come from a place that has one single
entity that governs all the police it's
natural that you would think that well
you could actually change things
in terms of policings or or prisons
pretty easily by bringing politicians to
beer but that's that's just not the way
it is here in america you know
what other what other questions that
people have or points that they want to
make or
so nicholas how does dialectical
materialism apply to politics or
political situations there's no answer
to that i mean
uh there's no agreement on among
marxists about what dialectical
materialism means you bump two marxists
together and you get conflict between
them typically
and there's nothing a fellow marxist
will you know spend more time on than
attacking another fellow marxist so that
i think that's kind of a non-starter
um you don't you don't need to do
diamond in order to think about things
in in terms of class i mean we can see
that from marx who had to attack every
other person who thought of things in
terms of class as not being good enough
um so that that one's
uh just not going to
you know get you anywhere i mean and the
other thing you have to think about is
if you're approaching things in a very
dogmatic way in america you will never
get anything done politically if you
walk into a school board meeting and
you're like here's what dialectical
materialism has to say people just close
their ears i mean it's the same thing
when i'm like doing stuff with virtue
ethics if i'm talking to a bunch of
business people i don't tell them that
the stuff about emotional management
that that you know that i'm teaching
them is coming from thomas aquinas or
the stoics or aristotle until they ask
you know
all right um elijah says i don't know if
you're up to this sort of convo but is
getting rid of the police and
non-starter and communities that use
consensus and such policing is not
necessary yeah and there's almost none
of them
you know so yes if you if you have a
community that uses all sorts of other
things that are total alternatives to
police
cool
that ain't that ain't 99.9 of america
and even when you do have something like
that
there are going to be cases where you're
still going to have to call on the
police for something else so when you
say something as a non-starter you mean
it's really not practical i mean
anything can be imagined
but being able to do something about it
you know that's that's something totally
different
all right ken says coming from a country
with a national health care system the
amount americans have to pay for health
care is obscene the nhs isn't perfect
but it's free for users yeah and you can
say that about almost any developed
country
in the world that um i mean just going
to canada is is like should be
eye-opening for americans the amount of
stuff that we have to pay there there's
so much
extra
costs built in at every single point
that don't need to be there and are
basically there to
make money from medical suppliers and
make money for insurance companies and
make money for the hospital groups
themselves as i pointed out often owned
by non-medical uh entities including
venture capitalists
it's it is really obscene and it's weird
that americans
for the most part don't get it and will
buy into stupid uh propaganda like well
you know if we had a national health
care system you know we'd have death
panels and you wouldn't get to pick your
doctor all you got to do is like look at
another country and see that that's
that's bs right
um eric w has a very broad question is
destruction of property ethically
justifiable yeah i mean we do it all the
time
the question you really mean to ask is
when is destruction of property
ethically justifiable and that's a
separate topic that we're not going to
discuss here um but everybody destroys
some property i'm i'm destroying some
right now i'm destroying this coffee
that and i own that coffee right
the frosty liked your point on needing
more local accountability for police
would you extend that same view to areas
outside of the police yeah of course
we should have accountability on
anything that affects our lives
education
is part of that health care is part of
that
the transportation networks are part of
that you know when they remove a bus
line here in milwaukee that drastically
affects a lot of low-income people's
ability to move from place to place you
know
um
our parks you know uh which were you
know very fortunate to be blessed with
because of our socialist past here in
milwaukee they thought that you know
parks were an important thing to have
and so we have a lot of green space here
if we don't protect it it i mean there's
actually proposals to like sell off the
parks again to
various businesses
um
you really really have to watch your
local government here
in the united states and it can be very
dismaying because they often act with
impunity because because you know there
isn't a lot of accountability
mark smith asks why don't many americans
want to change things do you think this
is the libertarian culture so prominent
there will the federal system ever be
able to do more there so i don't think
it's the case that most americans don't
want to change things i think most
americans do want to change things they
want to change them for their picture
the better and they have no road map
other than those provided to them by
you know ideologues in media
or by politicians who you know
either either our decent people and then
often have very complex proposals that
are nuanced or are just bullshitters who
manage to get their way into office and
who are lying to the people
it is difficult to figure out how to
really change things and it is
demoralizing and dismaying to find out
that you can
bring a perfectly well thought out
rational thing to the school board and
get booed and dismissed by a bunch of
you know [ __ ] essentially or people
who want to hold on to power so i i
don't think that most americans don't
want to change things
um i don't think that it's it's
part of a libertarian culture
um although you know we do have you know
libertarians and um
the republican party i would say right
now is committed to fostering a kind of
toxic
idea of individuality and freedom
that i guess probably does have its
roots in libertarian theory although
libertarian theory covers a wide range
um
but this like freedom without
responsibility
and you know keep everything you know
the way i i remembered it as being
um that's that's motivating a lot of
fake conservatives because they're not
really conservatives um in any real
sense of the term
um today
that that may be said to have
libertarian roots that might be a good
thing to explore later on would the
federal system ever be able to do more
in this stuff yeah
if we wanted if
if the politicians here's the problem
the federal system is really run by
politicians who manage to get themselves
elected in their states
by careerists
and by lobbyists
the lobbyists are representing the
interests of corporations primarily or
other interest groups not ordinary
americans
even the ones that claim to speak for
ordinary americans like aarp the
american association of retired people
not really i mean it's you know it's
it's a massive lobbying group that
throws a lot of money around um and i
don't think is particularly
representative
i don't see a lot of great prospects for
the federal government doing an awful
lot of help there but it could be
piecemeal like you know for example
the fact that we now once again have the
pell
grant supporting prison education the
second chance pell program which took uh
republicans and democrats coming
together which i i was participating in
for a while here in wisconsin
that's a sign of a small step forward
right
so
it is possible to
change some things
but the federal government is
you know it's great at fighting wars
it's great at you know
in influxing money into things it's
great at pressuring other countries to
do stuff but it's not it's not
particularly
good at the local level i would say
um
i'm going to skip the thing on
cybernetics and systems theory because
it's not really germaine here
um cody the finnish journalist
onopartonin posits that citizens of
nordic countries have more freedom
than americans because they get
government help with necessities like
health care and education yeah you don't
deposit it that's a fact
not having to worry
about what what's going to happen when i
get sick or my kid gets sick or my
parent gets sick
is an incredible
freedom from stress
you know if if you want to get an idea
about what americans used to think
freedom looked like
look at franklin delano roosevelt's four
freedoms speech from back you know in in
the 30s and 40s and it'll show you how
far we've we've gone you know
um
yeah education being you know not having
to worry that your kid is going to bring
home covid because the school
cow towed to a bunch of you know
anti-anti-vaccine nut jobs because
you're stuck in some red you know some
red county like is the case for my kids
you know uh
that is for peace of mind and there's a
lot of other things that go along with
that having an actual robust safety net
means means that you can move from job
to job so you don't have to be working
at amazon you know getting uh micro
managed and having to pee in jars
instead of take a break
over the over the course of your life
you can if you don't like a job you can
switch to it now we're in an interesting
time with respect to job stuff because
employers are realizing that
there's a lot of people opting out
because and it's not because of our
massive unemployment benefits that's
just republican talking points have been
quite silly i mean nobody's really
getting a lot of unemployment benefits
um they're not they're they're often not
enough to like you know
pay rent with let alone you know
put food on the table and pay your car
insurance and all these other things
that you need to do
um but there's you know we're going to
see wages going up starbucks just
announced you know 15 across the board
because they're scared of not having
workers right
so
all right um
hawkins emily hawkins says it seems like
you think we need an infrastructure to
access accountability and dependency
across local entities are you able to
spell out at all what this might look
like
no i'm sure it's going to it's not going
to be an overall infrastructure it's
going to be people doing things on the
local level and maybe those things
catching on when other people are like
wow you know
here's a prime example so when we had
hurricane katrina right and everybody
evacuated new orleans
new orleans residents were located in
all sorts of cities like chicago or san
antonio or all these other places
only half of them came back to new
orleans why
because living in another place made
them look around and say
wow new orleans was really [ __ ] up
i can't believe i put up with that
[ __ ] my whole friggin life
you know this isn't perfect i mean think
about chicago right this isn't perfect
but it's like light years ahead of new
orleans in terms of like the cops not
you know uh beating me up as much or
being able to find a job you know or
being able to get access to
to healthcare or stuff like that so i
think that you know having models that
are well publicized can do something but
i don't think there's going to be some
sort of infrastructure for
accountability
i'm not optimistic about that it has to
be done at the the local level you know
um
so
mfds something something do i think
republicans are planning to overturn the
2024 election if democrats
win if this is true isn't that
essentially violent um
well of course it's it it's violent if
you're overturning an election
are republicans planning it yeah
probably but
republicans are so
so far out in lala land right now we
should probably just assume
that if somebody is still supporting the
republican party they're a nut job
i mean you could say well what if you
live in a red state and all your
neighbors are red staters
well i mean i know plenty of people who
like look around at their neighbors and
they're like holy [ __ ] these people are
nuts
you know
so yeah we can probably count on that
and that's why independents like me
are going to be voting anti-republican
probably the rest of our lives because
that party isn't going to fix itself you
know
eric said i meant destruction of
property in the context of political
protest to bring public attention to an
issue totally depends on the
circumstances right i mean you're
looking for some general answer about is
destruction of property okay it depends
like so many other things when we put
our boots on the ground
um
elijah says i've been reading a lot
about
how a more clear definition of right and
left in politics is as hierarchy and
authority
right versus freedom and equality what
do you think of that i think those are
just complete abstractions and and you'd
probably do way better not to buy into
things like that
um
politics is complicated what counts as
right is a vast amalgam of a whole bunch
of different motives and groups
same thing what counts as left these
things change historically over time
beware people like jonathan height you
know
talking about conservatives are all like
this liberals are all like this that is
as crappy as that men are from mars
women are from venus nonsense that that
people spout i wouldn't buy into that
sort of thing you're going to find both
motifs represented in both sides and
it's way more complicated than just two
sides you know
so
um
any other questions comments it looks
like we've kind of reached the end
of uh
of the
ones that are posted
um
i'm going to take the opportunity of
some coffee
anything in particular about this notion
of their not being systems
um
because that's really where i want to
put the focus today mark says do you
think the nation state is a viable form
of political community depends on the
nation state and if we're talking about
political community in any robust sense
the answer is probably no unless you've
got a small nation state like you know
we talk about the nordic countries
france is probably
already a little bit too large great
britain you know to be able to do that
um to have a real sense of community and
have politics which is deliberation
among people about
how to move forward the vast nation
states you know china india the united
states
russia brazil
indonesia which is a massive country
probably too big
to really be anything like a
political community in a robust sense
and not just to be a whole bunch of
elites
and transactional stuff and you know
institutions doesn't mean that you can't
do decent politics within those contexts
but
yeah
uh sahil what are my thoughts on mark
fisher's capitalist realism i haven't
read the book so i only know the premise
of the book um i think that you know the
idea that we can only think out things
within the horizon of capitalism
um i mean we've had we've heard that
tune before right it was
enunciated by fukiyama um
i don't know that
that it's it's uh
a hard and fast case i really do need to
read the book um
hawkins uh with accountability being
established at the local level i thought
you were saying earlier a fundamental
issue is that there isn't any connecting
system linking these local entities
yeah but that's not me calling for an
infrastructure
i'm saying that there this is the
reality that we're in
and yeah you can establish
accountability on a local level it's
hard you gotta like be paying attention
to what these
slippery bastards are doing all the time
and the slippery bastards that aren't in
the chambers but are like bankrolling
people you know so if you if you live in
a
uh a small town you gotta actually see
what the city planners and the board are
doing you know
you you can't just wait until the last
minute when there's an issue and you're
like oh we need to go in with signs and
say stuff about this you got to be
watching these people all the freaking
time and that takes time and that takes
effort and that's tough to do and we we
need kind of a division of labor when it
comes to that maybe some of us need to
be the ones who walk in
and sit in a on court stuff and we're
like well that judge seems crooked i
better like tell somebody about that and
maybe some need to be the ones watching
the cops and some need to be the ones um
watching the the school board and things
like that right
and it
requires us to do an awful lot of extra
work
all right elijah says i want to say
disagree due to how you can still very
much track the right and left ideologies
throughout history no you can't actually
you can only do that by engaging in
massive
abstraction
and storytelling and stuff like that the
closer you get to the real
history the more you're gonna see that
that that's that's not really the case
uh mark says what form of political
community do you think would best allow
for local direct democracy
um i i mean it seems that part of the
difficulty is achieving accountability
across multiple levels of authority yeah
and and avoiding
other
entities coming in and
using their massive amount of economic
or or political power to screw things up
you know
i would say that in a lot of cases it's
very difficult to stand up against the
forces of corporations
what kind of political community would
best allow for local direct democracy i
mean i local direct democracy is a
political
organization but it's very difficult to
have for very long isn't it i mean we do
have to have representation and and we
do have to have some things that are not
elected offices so the whims of people
can't like you know rearrange
automatically
you know who's getting things done in
very boring jobs you know
um
all right let's see sahil says given the
rise of technology
and in a way a sort of anti-humanist
acceleration as cybernetic that dwells
in the neolis worldview where do you
personally think things will go i mean i
don't know that many people who are
actually anti-humanist accelerationist
cybernetic outside of you know some very
small communities uh that
i participate in the average person on
the street is not like let's accelerate
capitalism and let everything burn you
know and see what sorts itself out
um i think most people are just feeling
that they're being drawn along for the
ride
um and that can lead itself to a
different kind of nihilism and nihilism
of pessimism and despair where they're
like [ __ ] it i can't get anything that i
need done and what am i going to do with
my kids you know
uh but that's not that that sort of um
all is lost therefore accelerate um
thing where are things gonna go i don't
know i don't have predictions about that
i'm not a i'm not a prognosticator
myself
uh
what do you do when so much of the
population has become violent hungry far
right nut jobs how do you bring them
back to reality you don't you you're not
you're not some sort of person who's
responsible for bringing them all back
to reality
massive
long-standing cumulative forces along
with their own decisions have turned
them into what they are
no single thing that you're going to do
is going to fix that i mean the most
that you can do is like you know
maintain the connections with the ones
that you
maybe are related to and
you can push back once in a while if
they don't block you or ban you or stuff
like that
you know like when my dad talks about
going to watch fox news you know every
once in a while i'll say you know you
probably should watch something else
other than that you're a smart guy
and uh why are you feeding yourself crap
like that you know um
but you know
there there isn't going to be some some
vast
fixing things for these people i mean
what we're seeing is that um
as they refuse vaccinations and you know
refuse to wear masks and stuff like that
more of them are getting sick
unfortunately it's their poor kids who
are also getting sick as well
um and they're getting us sick too
so you know
i i don't i don't know it's not like
there's gonna be some some uh
pulling them out of this in some way and
we're at a dangerous point in in history
because there's so much of this stuff
um
trey says one of my thoughts on harry
eckstein's congruence theory never heard
of the guy so i don't know um hawkins uh
division of labor across the general
populace for engaging politics is a
really great idea any thoughts on how to
get started on trying to organize people
in this type of energy none at all
i'm not i'm saying a division of labor
would be needed i'm not saying that we
we organize it i you know i'm just
saying that's what would have to happen
um i i don't know who would organize
that i suspect it's going to be a lot
more
individual people doing the work and not
trying to like allot it out
and say okay you're responsible for this
you're responsible for for this
um
all right um
evil dust most of my family with the
exception of my mother and stepfather
are completely deranged
the things they believe now because the
trump fad make my head spin is pretty
disturbing yeah it's i mean trump
catalyzed some of what's worst in
american culture and politics
and it's going to be very difficult to
to change that
you know i have i have no problem myself
with
banning blocking
not engaging with with people who you
say are you know you can tell
that there's something wrong with them
now some people might say oh you have a
duty to to engage with them
no you don't
no more than you have a duty to engage
with
people who are you know um part of a
noxious death cult so
you know
ricky says my political philosophy
starts with the apology ends with the
prince well okay i mean anybody can have
whatever political philosophy they want
but i mean
dropping names doesn't doesn't mean
anything the apology can be interpreted
in many ways the prints can be
interpreted in many ways it's not as if
they they by themselves as abstractions
mean anything kevin says agreed with
division of labor for oversight
grassroots consortium as possible
structure
fueled by regional taxes getting
regional taxes out of politicians to pay
for grassroots structure good luck with
that
that might be something that's possible
to do in a few
states that have their own culture but
that wouldn't fly here in wisconsin
that wouldn't
work at all
sahil says
do i feel there should be significant
investigations on self versus digital
self sort of thing that came after the
internet
i don't know what significant
investigations means here in a political
context
so i you know
do you mean in the sense of like
that should be a
theme for philosophy or something or are
you talking about people impersonating
other people
because we've got these you know uh
possibility of of um
creating fake personas
in the
internet with the digital self i'm not
sure what the actual question is there
all right
so
you know
well while there's a pause here i'm
going to say long story short i don't
have a lot of proposals when it comes to
these things this is more of a diagnosis
than a
program for
fixing things you know
mark says do you think when a given
system is failing it's acceptable for a
community to act outside of that system
to meet their own needs i mean i think
that that a given system is almost
always acting outside of its own system
and bringing in outside actors
you know looking for help elsewhere
models elsewhere i think that's the
normal
case for systems whether we're talking
about political systems economic systems
educational systems there's always no
system is a closed
entity for very long you know
eric boy you really just won't let this
issue go what criteria would you use to
decide when property destruction for
political change is justified
i mean i that's not something i have an
answer for right now in a broad abstract
way i don't know why you're why you're
so worried about that particular issue
um i would probably look at it in a
fairly utilitarian way you know
if you're putting me on the spot i would
say what what's the the point of doing
it you know and i would also ask like um
is the entity whose property being
destroyed are they like you know able to
replace it very easily it's very
different to like burn down a single
family's house and to you know burn down
a corporate headquarters the
corporations got insurance for that sort
of crap right it's not the same thing
but i'm not sure why you want to turn
this particular issue about systems into
answering this this thing that seems to
be stuck in your craw about that
dark lord says um
if the if this all the circle people
from aristophanes speech in the
symposium desert this is not even
remotely relevant to so i'm not gonna
bother with it
jay why does the state of wisconsin
arrest and incarcerate so many young
black males okay so that's a good
tangible question to work on
um racism is a is a significant part of
it um
the kind of legislation that we've put
into place and the way that policing
works
in uh wisconsin is a major part of it
right um drug crimes um are not like
something that's enforced across the
board without you know respect to race
and
um there you know there was a massive
prison building initiative in wisconsin
under tommy thompson the former
republican governor
um
in the 1990s
if you know some of the the back history
of this and when you build prisons
you there's a tendency to want to find
people to fill those prisons because
those prisons are
economic pro projects as a matter of
fact there was a point where i remember
this in the 1990s where people were
putting out wow you're spending more on
prisons than you are in education what
the hell is going on there you know
so that is is a massive part of it
we also have some pretty significant
segregation and intergenerational
poverty here in the milwaukee area as
you may know we of the large cities in
the united states we are considered the
most segregated you wouldn't guess that
from the downtown here where
you know in the environing areas
where everything is is uh you know very
integrated um but go
you know
three and a half miles north go
two miles south go
uh five miles west of here and you will
find some very very segregated
communities and that that's that's a
good part of it
and these are important these are the
sort of important questions to ask i
would say when it comes to these systems
you know you don't want to just ask why
why are
african-americans you know a higher part
of the
incarcerated population nationwide
because the answer may be different in
some respects in texas than it is in
wisconsin than it is in california you
know you want to ask about why in
wisconsin why in milwaukee
y and eau claire you know all all of
these
sorts of things
[Music]
all right uh
honor rod can there ever be a return to
fact and honesty from our
post-truth-soaked age if you think that
there was ever a time of truth and and
fact and honesty
um somebody has sold you a line of
[ __ ] because read some some
political philosophy going all the way
back you know it's a plato uh and you're
going to find that this these are
problems we've been struggling with the
entire time
uh here's an interesting question from
retro gamer um in the context of a new
duran duran album which i'll have to
listen to because i'm a big duran duran
fan
uh popular music unites rather than
divides okay i think there's something
to be said about that
in a minute
doesn't the musician lyricist and poet
do more for humanity than a political
economy
so it depends i mean musicians are great
at raising awareness
they're not great at producing
structural change some kinds of music
are better at that
um but it's very easy for
for it to get co-opted i mean look at
how
so much counter-cultural music
is now i mean i i
my wife and i watch football games on tv
right and when i hear like ac dc or ozzy
osbourne getting played
on on the football thing i'm like holy
crap i mean when i was listening to that
stuff as a kid the football jocks you
know that would have been anathema to
them to listen to that sort of crap in
the stadium you know
things can get co-opted super easy and
so i i don't i mean duran durian
they're a group that actually called
attention to that think about their
album pop trash right
which i think was much more successful
than than you two
and
their you know supposed you know post
modern albums calling attention to you
know late capitals i think duran duran's
better at that sort of thing than than
u2 is
um
popular music doesn't necessarily unite
um
it can divide especially when they take
serious stance great example of an
artist
who gets considered divisive who i'm a
huge fan of by the way
is lizzo
i think her calling
calling out [ __ ] is awesome when it
happens
but um
a lot of people you know complain about
her and i think a lot of it's you know
the fact that that she's black and
overweight and stuff like that and a
woman you go all these other things that
can roll into it people's uh secret uh
hatreds you know coming out but
you know if you're if you're really
using your music to take a stand you're
gonna be controversial so a lot of a lot
of popular music doesn't do that or
they're super super vague about it or
they just reinforce stuff i mean
look at a lot of um country music
um and how it you know it plays off of
traditional gender roles and you know
apple pie and mom and the american flag
and you know blah blah blah blah blah
you know i mean it's it's set up
basically to
make uh insecure white people feel good
about themselves
um for driving their big truck that they
don't need
to their shitty job right
and we can say similar things about
other kinds of music and some music is
just escapist
that was one of the very common
criticisms
years and years and years ago about
heavy metal uh interestingly in relation
to punk was that punk oh it's political
you know heavy metal is just escapism
into like dragons and rainbows and
swords and stuff like that right
but look at what happens when bands
take political stands
um iron maiden took political stands
some of the fan base were like shut up
and play so i i don't know about that
you know i think there's potential for
musicians to do things but i don't think
i don't think that they're it's like a
natural um
better than the boring guy who sits in
the back
of the public's school board thing in
his writing notes and then goes to goes
to a blog and type some stuff and he's
like can you believe the [ __ ] the
school board did you know
uh
all right chaku greetings from india the
question the relevance of international
relations as being able to distinctly
form theories of political action on the
international scale as opposed to state
level
not related to what we're talking about
really at all i mean the point is
you know this is not about international
relations this is much much more
granular than than that
uh colors of gaming do you believe that
emotivism is a huge issue in our
political discourse do you think trying
to move away from that could help our
current situation so emotivism is a
meta-ethical theory that's actually
not it's not really meta-ethical it's
ethical um because all meta ethics
breaks down into ethics sooner or later
um
and it says that all we really are doing
when we're using politic you know
when we're using moral language which a
lot of political languages
is trying to express our points of view
our preferences our emotions our desires
or to get other people to see things the
same way yeah a lot of a lot of things
are like that uh if mcintyre who's known
for making that critique is right this
has been going on for you know uh quite
a long time several centuries actually
and can we move away from it yeah in
limited ways you got to work on yourself
first
you're probably not going to change
society radically in that way even if
you produce a great book
um
elijah here's here's a good question
what do you think about the role of
walkable cities in urban development and
further augmenting these systems
yeah so
great point about some really concrete
things
urban sprawl playing a big role in
schooling job availability we have a
very similar issue here in milwaukee
which is not a particularly walkable
city in a lot of places
we were just having a big discussion
about
the division of the city we talked about
the segregation of the city
that's going to be produced by widening
one of the highways
and
the state is pushing this and the city
doesn't want it
and
people have pointed out that the net
effect of this is going to make it
tougher for for people from the
largely african-american very often in
intergenerational poverty some of the
poorest zip codes in the nation
uh places in the city to go west and and
be able to get to jobs
this is very very important this and
it's not just being walkable
although that's that's a major part of
it
but having good public transportation
networks you know um
chicago
is an advantage over milwaukee because
they have the l trains you know
um we we just have buses we have we do
have a street car
that and it's a new streetcar and it
doesn't go very far it doesn't go to the
places that it needs to to really
produce
major change within
uh the city in terms of accessibility so
that that's a great point
uh marks as i see people i still see
people talk about what happened to the
dixie chicks i think they were called
yeah they were the ones who were country
and then they took a stand against uh
gulf war ii right
and they were told to shut up and sing
and this happens a lot you know
um i mean it happens to me in terms of
like if i express political views people
are like stick to philosophy as if
philosophy isn't connected with politics
right do only explain aristotle don't
talk about the implications for for you
know american society or stuff like that
um
retro gamer says don't we need escapism
in good measure there's the key term
good measure to find ourselves yeah and
maybe also to do some self-care the
trouble is that escapism can become just
escapism
and then produce a kind of
passivity or looking away from from
things that are going on elijah says
love that history of music you see that
in hip-hop as well especially in his
crossing with metal punk yeah i mean if
you think about like old what's not what
wasn't at the time old school hip-hop
but is now old-school hip-hop
think about the band arrested
development um
they they were very politically active
right
and they had some they had some great
songs and they were they were critiquing
the larger society they were also
critiquing what was going on in the
hip-hop scene
and i think that you know that sort of
message could be could be very helpful
and they did draw on other um
i mean
hip-hop by its own nature i would say is
a hungry
genre in terms of like you know looking
for stuff coming from other places to
sample um
good you know great example of that in
metal is the use of uh
the riff from jamie's crying
and what was it in i think uh funky
called medina um
my wife would be somebody who'd be able
to come up with millions of examples
because she listens to a lot more of
that i'm you know mostly metal
um
all right uh
florian says what do you think an
individual can do to create structural
changes in a society
probably
not an awful lot um as an individual
trying to create structural changes in
society you can create
avenues for it or possibilities for it
or if you're super lucky and everything
comes together and you happen to be the
one who's in charge at a certain point
you can maybe do something but all you
can do is little little parts here and
there you know
uh sahil oh there's a great question is
representation in arts and media truly
important given in reality the same
people are facing human rights abuse
feels like performative however good the
intent yeah i think that that i mean
representation can be
helpful because it allows people to say
oh yeah that's that's a possibility for
me or finally we get a chance or stuff
like that but that's it right so ursula
k le guin in making
uh most of the inhabitants of earth sea
copper-skinned or black-skinned people
as opposed to the the white-skinned
cargs and making her hero
ged a dark man
um friends with a much darker man uh
vetch from the the southern isles um she
recounts people coming up to her most
mostly african-americans but but also
other people of color saying
it's really important to me that you did
this um because i finally had a hero i
could like see as is you know connected
to me
that only gets you so far and it is
liable to co-option a you know prime
example of this
was the united colors of benetton stuff
that we now use you know if you say the
united colors of benetton people think
tokenism
um and when you look at like
um the brochures
or websites for colleges and
universities for recruitment you know
they make sure to like show everybody
who's there on campus they don't show
the self-segregation happening in the
cafeterias or
in
the frats and sororities or
in the places where students hang out
they don't show
the very different you know completion
rates for colleges or the racism that
that you know can happen within the
classroom you know a
student being picked out and being told
okay you're the token so and so speak
for your people here
um
changing that's much more important
right
all right uh
thomas if there is no system but
endocrine connect the systems what are
those smaller systems
ultimately made of people and laws
sometimes laws sometimes not sometimes
rules sometimes regulation sometimes
informal procedures sometimes
histories sometimes relationships
between families
there's no there's no single answer for
that
eric a lot of folk and country isn't
conformist you know and you bring up you
know two examples what do you got three
dixie chicks sure but a lot of it is
so what you know i mean you can always
find exceptions to the rule
um the shock doctrine how would you
define the concept of meta-narrative i
wouldn't define it i'm not a definitions
guy
um so
that doesn't do much uh elijah says
atlanta has 80 of people stuck in the
same socio economic status they were
born in largely due to how difficult it
is to access better schools jobs
products without a car that is a major
problem here in milwaukee too that is a
major problem i would say across
american cities
and um it also affects people in rural
areas incredibly uh as well and it
affects people who live in suburbs and
just don't learn how to drive because
maybe they're disabled you know
um this this is a really this is a
significant problem
for americans
it can be for canadians as well um it's
not as big of a problem i would say for
a lot of people in europe although it is
a problem in france because so much is
centered in the capital that's what the
you know um uh yellow the yellow vests
were about rising gas taxes you know and
in accessibility
um
[Music]
kevin has a question about gandhi that
i'm going to
pass on here
because i don't see it as particularly
relevant
chaku comments on marshall mcluhan's
idea that we have atomized matter
weaponized and at the same time return
to nomadic state that i don't think that
this has anything to do with the topics
here uh ffa says same goes for all the
cities in turkey well it's interesting
to read
that you really need a car rather than
being able to um
to access public transportation or walk
around and elijah says he's got to leave
soon i actually got to leave myself um
pretty pretty soon because i got to get
to some other
stuff um
recommendations good intro text to
political theory i mean i i don't i'm
not a a sort of intro
text person i i when i teach i teach
primary texts usually so i haven't been
like surveying
um anything contemporary that's that's a
particularly good intro text
um
intro text the philosophy metal artists
i mean
i can give you some suggestions about
that
um
with as with any
field you want to begin near the
beginning but you don't want to be just
beholden to the beginning so if you want
to understand
what metal was and what it became
um and what what it still is today you
want to look at the classic artists um i
mean i would i would actually suggest
going to the videos in the classic metal
class that scott truly and i have done
over the last couple years
but you know what's what's the
beginnings of of metal something that's
recognizable black sabbath deep purple
uriah heap ufo scorpions
montrose
blue easter cult
you know judas priest these are like the
early on bands that you really want to
go to led zeppelin of course but led
zeppelin is kind of an outlier in many
respects
um
and then you you know you want to look
at
you know what happened with different
movements like what was going on in the
la scene what happened with the new wave
of british heavy metal and that'll keep
you busy for a while
um
all right sahil is machiavelli sort of
misunderstood
um
people say machiavellian with a negative
connotation which i get i mean
the negative connotation is not evil or
vile it's manipulative that's that's the
negative connotation which i get and
then he stands for freedom people seem
to gloss over that
yeah i mean people should be reading not
just machiavelli's the prince but his uh
discourses on livy if they want to
understand what machiavelli actually
stands for
um and they want to read the prints
attentively too many people read it as
if it's like a how-to manual about how
to be a
manipulative dominating jerk when it
really has a lot of cool political
theory in it like when he says yeah the
rich are going to be pricks to the poor
so you got to find some way to reign
those rich people in you know um he's
got a lot of great great points like
that so thomas says motorhead yeah
motorhead tank you know a lot i mean we
could go through a whole like list of
bands but
this really isn't the time and place for
it um
shock doctrine are there useful ways to
understand the concepts we use in lieu
of defining them i approach politics
through definitions mainly
well if you approach politics through
definition then you're going to have a
very
hard time of it because definitions are
abstractions and particularly when they
come to things that as aristotle says
hold for the most part they often you
know are going to have all sorts of
exceptions to them i mean if you like
being up in your head and just thinking
in terms of abstractions then
definitions are great and do we have
other ways of doing things yeah i mean
actually looking at how things are
generalizing from them which doesn't
mean necessarily defining them
doing family family relation definitions
or family resemblance definitions rather
than trying to do a definition like that
i mean definitions are great for
abstract deductive reasoning like in
mathematics they're not great for
most other things they're just helpful
little little tools and
[Music]
they're only one of many i mean
we we have a lot of tools at our
disposal to use
uh words how do you think direct
democracy should be implemented i don't
think there's a single answer to that
referendum direct votes on issues
councils government selected by lot a
mixture of different systems i mean this
presumes that we think that we should
have direct democracy
i don't know that direct democracy is a
thing that we need to have in every case
i i don't want to direct democracy when
it comes to
running a school for example you know i
want people who
actually know what the hell they're
doing to be in charge of running a
school rather than like everybody votes
there's some things that i think we
should probably vote on but
and and there's no one answer to that i
mean all these things that you're
talking about are possibilities but some
of them may be more useful for some
communities than for others right
um
all right so i'm gonna bring it to a
close a lot of good
ideas suggestions comments and stuff
like that but i got to go and
upload a
hegel video and get ready for the half
hour hegel
uh patreon exclusive
session and also get some food in my
belly since i i only had a bagel this
morning so
woke up kind of late um
this has not been a particularly
productive month in part because my wife
and i
got um
covid and flu shots
the same day last week and so
you know massive side effects and this
has been this has been the first day
that i'm like feeling really human so
glad all of you could join me we'll do
these again starting
next month it's been a couple months
since i've done these and we might i
might pick one of these other topics and
follow up on on that go go back through
the the comments and stuff and see what
else we should follow up on
um but i'll i'll see all of you and
yeah that's that's about it alright see
you later